So it's not only Chris Matthews on MSNBC that
in his panic about Bernie Sanders, recent
primary and caucus successes likened Bernie
to Nazis. We've actually been covering the
disinformation propaganda and the memes that
have been spreading and the American right
is in as much of a panic over Bernie Sanders
as his establishment, corporate media and
the democratic party establishment and the
right is now starting to spread disinformation,
equating Bernie to Hitler.
Now I want to look at one example today, which
in six different ways suggests that Bernie
Sanders is like Adolf Hitler. Now we have
to suspend disbelief for a moment because
when you say the Jewish candidate whose family
members were killed in the Holocaust by Hitler's
Nazis is like Hitler immediately, most people
would say, that doesn't make any sense, David.
Let's ignore that for now and just look at
what they assert. Let's look at these one
by one. The meme claims that both Hitler and
Bernie believe state power will fix their
respective countries. It's important to point
out that Bernie Sanders has no interest in
increasing state power, and in fact, Bernie
has been critical of how Donald Trump has
exposed that the executive branch probably
has too much power because Trump has been
able to completely flout and ignore laws and
norms. And do whatever the hell he wants.
So it is simply not true that Bernie is looking
to increase state power, uh, for these hegemonic
authoritarian reasons that Hitler wanted to
do. That. What Bernie believes is that government
involvement in a sensible and controlled way
will make some of our systems better function.
There are systems that aren't working well,
that have turned over too much power to the
rich and to corporations at the expense of
the average American. Bernie believes government
involvement in those systems will be better
for the average person. Secondly, they argue
Bernie and Hitler are the same because they
both proposed gun control. Now, this relates
to a meme that has spread that the Jews were
disarmed by Nazis, and if the Jews had not
been disarmed by Nazis and had rifles and
handguns, they could have successfully resisted
world war II period. That has been widely
debunked. It's an entire, we could do an hour
just on that, but it is both factually wrong
and it's wrong in its conclusions.
Bernie wants sensible gun control that most
Americans agree with. Gun control was already
strict in Germany before Hitler came to power.
Historians agree that guns would not have
allowed the Jews who made up just 1% of the
German population at the time to resist the
third Reich. And the idea that 1% of the population
with pistols and handguns was going to take
out, take out a very well armed police state,
uh, that ultimately became and worked with
and mold it into melded into the third Reich
is silly at its face and has been widely debunked.
The third bullet point is both Hitler and
Bernie promise political revolution. Now in
a sense, so did Donald Trump a revolution
where the swamp would be drained? Political
insiders would no longer have power. He failed
to do it. But this idea of revolution is so
vague that it becomes meaningless.
Hitler's revolution was one of a hegemonic
Germany invading other countries and killing
Jews likening it to Bernie Sanders, wanting
the U S to be more like the social democracy
of Denmark where people get healthcare and
public college paid for through taxes is laughable.
It is a semantic game that they are playing.
Number four, they bring out the term socialist.
The right-wing disinformation meme says, Hey,
Hitler called himself a socialist and Bernie
calls himself a socialist. Now, of course,
national socialist abbreviated as Nazi has
nothing to do whatsoever with democratic socialism
or in reality, what's social democracy? That's
what Bernie Sanders is proposing. This is
a semantic confusion that's being used to
trick low information. People who don't really
know much by throwing the word socialism and
without any context. Number five, Hitler blamed
Jews for Germany's problems. While Bernie
blames the rich for America's problems, this
is a really important one.
Bernie is not so much blaming the rich for
problems. Now, even if Bernie was blaming
the rich, blaming the rich is very different
than blaming the Jews, but put that aside
for a second. Bernie doesn't blame the rich
Bernie points to the super rich as evidence
that the system is not working. It needs to
be reformed. When Bernie says, look at the
super rich and corporations who often pay
little or less in taxes compared to people
who are just middle-class, that's evidence
that the system isn't working. The rich are
a side effect. The rich aren't the problem
as individuals. A very, very deceptive component.
And then lastly, both Hitler and Bernie wanted
heavily regulated economies. And again, this
is just a semantic game. A regulated economy
could mean anything from a communist, centrally
planned economy to social democracy or even
a totalitarian police state. Hitler wanted
to get involved in the minutia of people's
everyday lives in the authoritarian sense,
determine who gets to live, who gets to procreate.
Bernie wants to regulate the economy to prevent
bad actors in industry and bad actors who
limit the average person's ability to just
live a happy life and pursue happiness. So
this is one of those examples where you see
the full list with the deceptive language
and you start to think, man, may, maybe Bernie
is like Hitler. In some ways. The Mirasee
superficial analysis confirms that this is
merely disinformation and, uh, something that
we need to protect ourselves against given
the nature of the nature and the scope of
the disinformation that is floating around
already in the democratic primary. Um, very,
very ugly stuff. But we will do our best to
debunk it.